مرحبًا
، لقد حدثت
ثلاث هجمات حتى الآن ، هل لديك مسدس ،
أنا سيدني بريسكوت بالطبع لدي
سلاح ،
شيء ما بخصوص هذا واحد فقط أشعر
بشعور مختلف.
أحسنت صنعًا بعد
25 عامًا من الفيلم الأول بعد
10 سنوات من آخر فيلم ، كيف كان الأمر
وكأننا نعود معًا في موقع التصوير ،
إنه أمر رائع دائمًا
العمل مع نيفين كورتني ورؤية
بعضنا البعض في موقع
التصوير ، نعم ، أنا فقط لا أعرف أننا جميعًا  لقد
نشأنا معًا ، نعم نحن في الخامسة والعشرين
من العمر ، لذلك هناك الكثير من الحياة التي تحبه ، تشعر
وكأنها عائلية ،
إنها مثل
المعسكر الصيفي عندما نصنع هذه الأفلام ، لذا
فهو وقت جيد
تعرف فيه ما الذي أعجبني عندما
تدعم حقًا الجديد  يلقي آه
الانضمام إلى هذا الفيلم أه ما كان
يشبه العمل معهم
هؤلاء الرجال موهوبون جدًا كما تعلمون
وهو أمر مريح للغاية لأنك
لا تعرف ما إذا كان الممثلون
الجدد سيأتون وما إذا كانوا
سيعرفون  ماذا يفعلون وهذه
الكي  ds ليسوا أطفالًا وصغارًا هم
محترفون حقيقيون ويضخون طاقة
كبيرة لهذه الأفلام ،
وهم معجبون جدًا بأفلام
الامتياز ، لذا فهم متحمسون جدًا لأن
يكونوا جزءًا منها أيضًا وهذه الطاقة
مسكرة  إنه أمر رائع حقًا ،
لذا كان من الجيد العمل معهم
سامانثا ،
أنا أعرف من أنت ، لقد مررت
بهذا
الفيلم كثيرًا ،
هذا الفيلم مبدع جدًا والناس من
جميع أنحاء العالم يحبونه لماذا
يحب الناس هذا الامتياز  أعتقد
أن كل شيء يعود إلى ويس كرافن
وكيفين ويليامسون في كتابة ذلك السيناريو الأول
، نعم ، ثم
وجه الشبح هو
شرير رعب مبدع ، وبالتالي فإن القناع هو
رمز صوتي للغاية
ولكن يا
رجل وجيمس الكتاب الجدد  لقد
قمت بعمل مذهل ، نعم بات وتايلر مخرجان رائعان ،
وهل عملت في خمسة أفلام ،
كيف كان العمل في هذا الفيلم
دون أن يكون
كرافن
أه هو قليل من الكآبة وأيضًا
تعلم أنه من الرائع العمل مع المخرجين الجدد
أم أنا بالتأكيد  لقد شعرنا بغياب ويس
بالتأكيد ، لكننا أيضًا
شعرنا حقًا بوجوده في المجموعة التي تعلم
أننا كنا نناقشه كل يوم
كلما اتخذنا قرارات بشأن
أشياء اعتقدت أنه يجب تغيير شيء ما
، لطالما طرحنا ما
تعتقد أنه سيفكر
ماذا سيفكر  هل كان المخرج
يريد دائمًا هذه المعلومات فقط
ولذا فقد كان معنا كثيرًا
طوال الوقت
، هل أنت مستعد
لهذا
أبدًا يا
[تصفيق]
هناك قواعد معينة للنجاة
من الهجمات كانت كلها على أشخاص مرتبطين
بالقتلة الأصليين
أخبرني  مزيد من المعلومات حول الإنتاج ، يبدو
جميلًا ، كيف كان الوضع ،
هل قاموا ببناء كل ذلك في مرحلة سليمة ،
نعم
مسرح الصوت ومواقع مختلفة لدينا مذهلة ،
كان لدينا طاقم مذهل مصمم إنتاج رائع ،
نعم ، لقد كان ذلك شرفًا لنا
كن جزءًا من الفيلم ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم يا رفاق لأخذ
الوقت الكافي للإجابة على أسئلتي وأنا
متحمس حقًا للجميع لمشاهدته
قريبًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم.  أنت تهتم كثيرًا ،
شكرًا لك ،
مرحباً
، شرف